the new york post
it says a florida father is speaking out
after a school board cut off his
microphone as he denounced pornographic
material in classrooms claiming somebody
failed drastically in the mission to
protect young minds
bruce friedman is his name he's the
florida chapter president of no left
turn in education which works to restore
parental function in public education he
was silenced during a june 30th clay
county school district board meeting as
he read from a book he found at the
fleming island high school
and this exchange is just one you have
to see for yourself so let's play it
um tonight i'm going to give a sampling
from three books that are in our
libraries the fleming school
and the oakley school
and then we can discuss
you can discuss the process by which
these books get on the shelves because
there's a clay county employee that got
paid to put this book
lucky by alice sebold
i'm going to read things if there's
children watching
cover their ears he began to i'm going
to stop you right there sir i'm going to
stop you right there
turn the microphone off
turn off this microphone please
i've told you i'm stopping you
the reason i'm stopping you is because
these meetings are if you'll hush your
mouth for a minute and listen instead of
just talking you merely learn something
well
the problem is sir is these meetings are
broadcast there are people at home that
are watching it on youtube there are
people that are watching it on community
television are you going to listen
you're going to run your mouth
and you'll get it back but you'll get it
back to talk about something besides
reading pornography into a
public television set
well
let me explain something to
you are federal and state laws that
prohibit you from
saying the things that you're getting
ready to say on television
there are state laws that private and
federal communications laws that
prohibit you from publishing these
things to a child
you don't have the you don't have the
ability at this point to determine who's
watching the television show and for you
to say everybody cover your ears just
doesn't cut it
if you go to
if if you go to
television and you look before anything
that comes on that's offensive they have
it graded is r
nc 17 pg or g
or x
now
if if you
put something on the television without
that you are violating state and federal
law number one number two if you'll hush
him in and listen you'll learn something
wow
uh
first of all
this is really another reason why um
even though the two incidents are not
directly related another reason why i
don't have any problem with
the someone calling aoc a big booty
latinx is that um
because it's like it's disrespect but
these people i'm just lumping them all
together you know the people running
school boards aoc they're all in the
same camp
they have no respect for us whatsoever
they just they they you know what you
want to talk about scorn that scoring
they heap on us
every
second of the day and you hear it in
that exchange
you want to shut your mouth for a minute
who are you talking to
i thought the guy that was trying to
speak he kept us calm
better than i probably could i respect
that and um in the process he
illustrated something
very important
but part of which is he'd respond like
who the hell are you talking to you son
of a [ __ ] why don't you shut your mouth
if you tell it who do you think you are
that you could sit up there and tell me
to close my mouth that's not how this
works
you sit on a school board you're a
nobody you work for me
i tell you to shut your mouth and listen
to me
that should be the response and and what
is he saying um it's
it's illegal
this guy is saying it's illegal
to read this material out loud because a
child might hear it meanwhile
this is the material that he allows to
be in the schools that he oversees so
it's illegal for a parent to read it out
loud at a school board meeting but it's
not illegal to supply it to the kids in
the in the library at the school
have you ever looked at your credit card
statement and been shocked by the
interest rate did you know that you
could actually roll all of your credit
card debt into one monthly payment at a
lower fixed interest rate lower your
interest rate and save with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream rates start at 5.73 apr with
autopay and excellent credit plus the
rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the life of the loan you can get a
loan from five thousand to a hundred
thousand dollars and there are
absolutely no fees at all you can even
get your money back or you can get your
money as soon as the day you apply so
it's as quick as that livestream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver
just for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate interest rate
discount and you can save even more in
the process the only way to get this
discount is to go to
lightstream.com walls that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-n
walsh
subject credit approval rates range from
5.73 apr to 19.99 apr and include 5.5
autopay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit livestream.com
walsh for more information
just in incredible
and this brings me back to a point that
should be reiterated
um
i said yesterday that you shouldn't be
sending your kid into the university
system not the first time i've said that
uh you know how i feel about the public
school system because of stuff like this
okay because of the the
the indoctrination that goes on
the content that kids in these schools
are subjected to uh the messages and
everything else and also the people
running these institutions
and i got pushback yesterday as i have
many times in the past from people
saying as we were talking specifically
in that case with the university system
but i hear it also about the public
school system when i say get out of the
public school system homeschool your
kids and all the rest of it the pushback
that i get is that um
well
no that's that's cowardly that's where
we're giving up right we're uh you
we can't do that we need to fight for
these institutions we have to reclaim
and fight for these institutions rather
than abandon them
but but here's the problem we can't
okay you can't reclaim them as they are
currently constructed they have to be
destroyed and rebuilt
the public school system the fact that
something like that can even happen at a
school board meeting
everything from the tone the school
board member is taking the way he's
speaking to the other guy and and the
what they're talking about everything
about it
the fact that that a school board member
will sit there and say it's illegal for
you to read this out loud but we can
still give it to your kids
you know that just shows that the rot
in the school system goes all the way
down
it's at a structural level this is like
you know if you're buying an old
dilapidated home and you might think at
first
we could do a nice remodel and then you
look at it and you see no there's
structural damage this thing is beyond
saving it has to be demolished okay we
need to remodel this thing with a
wrecking ball which is how we need to
remodel the the public school system
metaphorically speaking and and then and
then rebuild something completely
different that's the only answer
the answer is not
to try and take over the left's
institutions as they are currently
constructed because they are the less
institutions they own them
and as long as you are inside them
you're at their mercy
abandon the institutions to the extent
that you can't build your own and you
can do that with education too
you know homeschooling may not seem like
an institution but it actually is there
are and as homeschooling parents we've
been involved in several and there are
you know you can get together as a
community of homeschoolers and build
your own co-ops build your own um
in effect your own small scale
educational system so it's not just you
you know taking the burden of um of
of this all on your own you don't have
to do that
so that's the answer
and then once we've abandoned these
institutions you don't even need the
wrecking ball because they'll collapse
on their own
the public school system they in order
to survive it needs your children it
can't survive without them it feeds okay
it's like a it's a parasite that feeds
on your kids
and then the other the other point that
i always have to
um
make sure to emphasize is that when it
comes to education you know you talk
about oh we need to fight for we need to
fight for the institutions well if you
send your kid to public school
or to a liberal university for that
matter you are not fighting to reclaim
that institution you're not you're not
doing the fighting you're not doing
anything you're just sending your kid
off your child is the one who you are
tasking
to to wage this war okay you're sending
your kid in and when especially when it
comes to public school system that is an
insane strategy
like it's hard enough for parents to
deal with these people you're gonna send
your seven-year-old in and say fight for
this institution
[Music]
asking way too much of your child to do
that i think
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated